avec l'apparition du mouvement me tout
en 2017 les masses sont conviés sur les
dérives sexuelles qui se déroulait
d'abord dans le petit monde du cinéma
puis progressivement dans le reste de la
société d'agression sexuelle
caractérisée un climat malsain qui
envahissait certaines entreprises de
nombreux spams ont pris la parole pour
faire éclater un tabou devenue
insupportable
aujourd'hui c'est l'animatrice karima
charni qui a décidé de prendre la parole
pour dénoncer les dérives sexistes et
parfois racistes dopé lors été victime
dans les médias elle revient notamment
sur une expérience dans l'émission de
radio loving fun co-animé à l'époque par
le docteur christian spitz une période
qu'elle a très mal vécu
je devais me battre pour que les mains
n'arrive pas sur ma poitrine sur mes
fesses quoi on n'en donnait je craque je
pleure duty stop et dérives dans les
médias déjà dénoncée par plusieurs
personnes sur les réseaux sandra muller
à l'origine du mouvement balances ton
port avait d'ailleurs accusé
publiquement les dérives de son
supérieur hiérarchique à la chaîne
equidia re pourtant c'est à faire dans
l'immédiat semblent faire moins parler
qu'ailleurs alors le harcèlement dans
les médias est il tabou qu'est ce que
vous en pensez les chéris isabelle toi
ma chérie ce que j'ai été victime de
deux versements de harcèlement c'est des
mecs lourdaud à main honnêtement au
travail toutes filles ici ne peut pas
dire qu'elle n'a pas subi mais au goût
des belles mains baladeuses ou autre je
me souviens d'être d'avoir eu des loyers
est bien là mais les contacts semaine
difficile il ya 10 15 ans et 20 26 et 15
ans non ça vraiment même nom mais bien
sûr moi je me souviens je dirait pas son
nom parce que je respecte infiniment sa
fin de saison blanc d'un avocat célèbre
avec qui un jour j'ai déjeuné et j'ai
fait comme je suis très bien élevés pas
violent j'ai fait tout le déjeuner en
lui coin sans sa main entre mes jambes
il a déjeuné tout le repas comme ça et
le serveur cheveux qui passe et se
disaient qu'est ce qui se passe là j'ai
bien évidemment régler en plus puisqu'il
avait les mains indisponibles et ensuite
quand je suis rentré mais on va pas
l'auteur y avait un hôtel à côté jeudi
mme banon mais je rentre bosser aves des
jours entre à davézé ça me titille
j'appelle l'hôtel et je leur dise que
vous avez une chambre réservée au nom de
ron le nom de l'avocat on dit non et une
à gauche dit est-ce qu'une chambre
réservée au nom de morini-bosc dit oui
non donc le mec non seulement mon
comportement que ça l'aurait fait dormir
avaient réservé une chambre
non non mais c est cool kids comme ça
t'as jamais rien dit non parce que je
suis maintenant mais lui lui seul après
clairement c'est un scandale c'est
incroyable histoire régime pour avoir
travaillé dans plein de boîtes de
production je voulais dire déjà que dans
les médias l'ambiance elle est très
différente des entreprises classiques
monde se tutoie
il ya des vannes ça se charrient après
il ya des limites les limites c'est
celle du harcèlement il ya des gestes
qui sont inacceptables à karima charni
elle parle presque d'attouchements dans
son interview elle adore car évidemment
c'est condamnable
après il ya des attitudes qui pose
question c'est pas vraiment commencé
perçue est ce que c'est du harcèlement
ou non et aujourd'hui c'est que cette
ambiance de mythe où elle pose des
questions est ce qu'aujourd'hui draguer
un ou une collègue de travail c'est du
harcèlement ou non est ce qu a appelé un
collaborateur ou un collègue à 2 heures
du matin pour parler travail c'est du
harcèlement certainement dire que oui
d'autres d'autres d'autres vont dire que
non donc tout ça je trouve que ça pose
question c'est des questions qu'il se
posait pas il ya quelques années et qui
aujourd'hui se pose vraiment il ya dur
ce que je suis d'accord avec guillaume
il a du harcèlement partout dans tout
l'état fia du harcèlement et le pire
c'est quand tu cherches à licencier
quelqu'un dans l'état foutu cherche à
licencier quelqu'un le harcèlement il
est terrible après moi car année karima
charni jeu l'adorent aussi c'est une
fille que j'adore j'ai toujours suivi ce
qu'elle faisait de l'ariège depuis
l'époque radio puisque après c'est
toujours pareil j'ai toujours le même
discours
quand j'entends is a changé de région
aurait tellement vie qui va avec tout de
suite après au commissariat balancer ce
mec là mais je suis dans un monde de oui
oui je rappelais monde et enfin toutes
celles ci mais tu es mais oui mon laisse
faire les mecs il avoué après coup ils
pensent qu'ils ont le droit de le faire
sur le harcèlement dans les médias
pareil c'est toujours des gens quand ils
sont plus en poste
ils disent il ya huit ans il ya six ans
on m'a fait ça c'était l'horreur c'était
terrible et dans mon monde de oui oui
j'aimerais tellement que cas chroniqueur
télé
une animatrice télé quand elle est en
poste qu'elle aille dire voilà cabane
ans sont pas faciles mais voilà c'est
pas facile parce que sinon tu perds ton
boulot c'est ça j'aimerais bien il
fallait ce genre à dire messieurs dans
mon monde de oui oui oui ça m'est arrivé
alors mais on a résisté lundi oui ça
m'est arrivé complètement je vais vous
raconter alors dans les rues d'haguenau
quand on se marre avec des garçons voilà
ça parle un peu cul ça me dérange pas on
va se marrer toi d'entre-nous okami mais
là j'ai vécu quelque chose de très
différent et d'assez difficile il ya 12
13 ans je commençais à la radio j'étais
au centuple avec moi
[Rires]
non c'est après avec moi non
9 10 ans et c'est un très bon groupe
radio parce que justement ils ont viré
cette personne ensuite aux questions là
moi je n'avais pas dénoncer parce que
j'avais eu peur en me disant moi je suis
une petite église et quoi inciter passé
c'est que au départ il ne me parlait pas
il ne m'adressaient pas la parole
il ne me disait pas bonjour si je venais
à plat en talons non il me disait je ne
vous dirai pas bonjour je ne vous
parlerai pas si vous êtes en basket les
travailler chez sarenza et en fait il
voulait absolument que je sois en talons
et il me demandait de marché devant lui
quand j'avais mes talons et une fois il
m'a convoqué dans son bureau ou non et
m'a dit vous montez dans mon bureau tout
de suite et donc là alors c'est sûr
c'est pas moi je le pense oui ça arrive
dans son bureau il c'est une atmosphère
qui fait vraiment peur c'est à dire que
là ils tournent autour de moi il me
parle il a une voix qui est glacial il
touche le bout de mes cheveux il tout
juste un petit peu mais jean-louis david
là il me demande si jamais je connais le
bondage quoi bon et demain si je connais
le bondage moderne qui me demandaient
ils me demandaient les scotchs connecte
à dallas je lui dis non je ne sais pas
ce que c'est il me dit eh bien vous
retourner tout de suite dans votre
bureau vous regardez sur google que
c'est fait vous roulez dans mon bureau
pour me dire ce que vous en pensez
et là je regardais je vois effectivement
c'est une pratique sexuelle on doit
s'attacher et s'est lancé avec des
cordes et donc là moi j'ai du côlon mais
je débute la radio et je dois remonter
dans son bureau pour lui dire ok bah
j'ai vu ce que ça vous devez vous êtes
remonté lui dire eh ben je suis revenu
et j'ai essayé de mettre ça en dit long
mais visiblement je vous fais mais le
souci c'est bon mais j'ai essayé alors
c'est pas drôle je reconnais c'est pas
drôle ce que j'ai dit ça me ressemble
l'humour c'est pas ça chez moi mais j'ai
essayé de trouver une pirouette pour
n'en avait jamais parlé
si vous en avez parlé après et je me
suis dit moi stagiaires ou lui qu'à la
direction qui est ce qui saute c'est moi
donc je n'ai rien dit à ma direction et
j'aurais dû parce que c'est une très
bonne radio et qu'ils ont viré peu de
temps après cette personne qui se son
assistant que ces plaintes pour
harcèlement sexuel et qu'il a été démis
de ses fonctions vous dites la question
c'est le harcèlement dans les médias est
il tabou alors je vais prendre
je vais prendre tout le monde à témoin
on le sait ce qu'ils sont comme ça
franchement on n'hésitera pas mais ils
sont connus dans tout litige va pas se
mentir il ya des tas de gens des gens
très connus qui se consacrait depuis
depuis des années ce fait le problème
c'est que personne
n'a osé dénoncer mais soit dans les
médias effectivement il y en a beaucoup
et on les connaît tous on les connaît
tous serré et ça c'est un vrai rôle
parce qu'effectivement aujourd'hui et si
la parole s'est libérée
si vous faites un sondage et si on parle
dans le métier dans notre métier est
évidemment ce qu'il comporte comme ça on
les connaît tous voilà alors moi je vais
vous dire un truc c'est que quand j'ai
commencé en salles aux usa bien gros
poste à france télévisions de l'amap
affronter lyon je vous parle quand j'ai
démarré dans ce métier ouais d'accord
j'avais 18 ans et 18 ans et j'étais
l'assistant j'avais l'a6 j'étais
l'assistant d'une grande chanteuse je ne
donne pas son nom et l'éditeur son
éditeur qui n'est plus à qui est décédé
m'a harcelé non pendant cinq mois en
bloquant dans sa bagnole me faisait me
faisais faisant venir dans son
appartement bloquant dans son
appartement j'ai dû sortir par une
fenêtre parce qu'ils allaient tout faire
mais avec les ballons mais c'est un mec
qui parle tout de suite ça fait rigoler
oui mais vous savez le harcèlement il
marque des deux côtés siph akloul déjà
d'en parler aujourd'hui c'est pas facile
mais j'en parle quand même c'est nicolas
lorsque je veux juste vous dire c'est
que le harcèlement il existe partout et
que à un moment donné moi j'avais 18 ans
je me suis cassé j'ai pas de diplôme moi
j'ai arrêté de travailler et j'étais
déjà arrêté l'école à 16 ans j'ai flippé
parce qu'un monde et j'avais quand même
mon premier boulot mais j'ai décidé de
partir après il s'est trouvé que j'ai
pas dit la vérité à la chanteuse qui m'a
dit de toute façon j'étais un imbécile
et que je réussirais pas dans ce métier
mais on s'est retrouvé très très vite à
énergie puisque deux ans après gta
énergie et et j'avais raconté cette
histoire à mike sweeney et ce qu'ils
avaient fait marrer mais se mutinent il
avait dit à ben justement il ya un ogre
aux patrons qui est là nicolas pernikoff
ça me fait plaisir de te le présenter il
va arriver
la personne a fait la gueule comme ça
parce qu'amélie est un abruti fin qu'on
n'a pas cherché à comprendre pourquoi je
suis parti un peu comme un voleur mais
je veux dire à un moment donné raymond
je le rejoins mais ce n'est pas que dans
les médias il faut arrêter les conneries
c'est par tous et partout par entreprise
et par tous les médias qu'est ce qui
s'est passé a abandonné dans la radio il
y avait pas mal d'hommes
c'était plutôt masculin la radio donc
effectivement côté un peu facile d'aller
raconter des conneries entre les mecs et
puis après de faire la même chose avec
tout ce que je veux juste dire par là
c'est qu'il faut oser il faut oser vous
voyez moi j'en parle aujourd'hui j'en ai
jamais parlé mais il faut oser il faut
se libérer un jamais ce que tu allais
jamais non j'y réfléchis ce matin
puisque je vous dis aujourd'hui les 50
donc enfin je peux en parler
sauf que le problème c'est que c'est
trop tard ça ne sert à rien la personne
d'abord elle est décédée
donc si ça se trouve
ces produits dits fois derrière donc
vous voyez j'ai servi à rien en faisant
ça donc ce que je veux dire aux gens
c'est ayez du courage
je sais que c'est compliqué que la
police n'a pas que ça à faire aussi que
les juges sont débordés en ce moment
mais il faut oser parler à votre
entourage à vos amis mais surtout ne
vivait pas avec ça parce que on ne peut
pas vivre avec ça et se clairement si
cher les gens à qui avoue non moi
pourtant j'ai voulu dans une carrière
accidentogène j'étais mannequin j'ai vu
des couturiers j'ai vu des photographes
on est dénudée on est en backstage et
puis après quand j'ai écrit des bouquins
j'ai rencontré des éditeurs des
journalistes aussi littérature donc
forcément oui il ya eu des relooking a
eu des lourds dingues il ya eu même des
gens qui cherchait un petit peu
l'intimidation dans les studios de
plaque contre lui un qui dit on voit
quand et où ça ça ça vous arrive et ça
m'est arrivé bien sûr mais sauf que moi
dans la seconde j'ai dit mais tu dégages
connard enfermé donc je me suis jamais
laissé faire de toute ma vie même avec
des couturiers gourdin de même avec des
photographes lourdingue même avec plein
d'artistes défunt des gens différents de
différents corps de métier parce que
nicolas l'a très bien dit ça arrive
partout ça arrive à l'hôpital ça arrive
dans les cabinets d'avocats mais je
pense que ce qui est très important
c'est que nous on parle souvent ici demi
tous deux ballons ce temps paraît tout
ça mais effectivement vraiment la raison
tant qu'on ne parlera pas au moment t et
tant que ça ne sera pas évolué au mans
on monte on ira voir les flics et aura
des instructions y'a rien qui changera
pas ce qui aura toujours une sorte de
complexe
non je peux pas j'ai peur et tout ça
voilà donc c'est assez compliqué
delphine j'aimerais avoir avoir votre
sentiment parce que vous êtes alors
toutes magnifiques mais c'est vrai que
delphine même si vous avez devant vous
avez été miss france voilà vous avez
franchement vous avez fait le tour de
france est ce que vous avez été vous
confronter à des rôles ou alors moi je
peux dire que ça ne m'est jamais arrivé
il ya des filles à qui ça n'arrive pas
aujourd'hui on cherche les quais
l'égalité des sexes je veux dire un gars
qui te met la main entre les cuisses
directement tu lui dis stop que tu te
lèves rousvoal à la télé c'est que de la
télé un job violent ça va pas tu changes
il faut la finale non mais après cela
nous donne son sentiment la loi de le
donner aux dix ans les chiens est-ce que
paraissait l'avenir il vaut mieux cela
vaut tourner la situation aujourd'hui
les filles on est des filles fortes moi
je préfère parfois mettre moi mal à
l'aise un garçon en étant tactile en lui
faisant un peu des blagues on rentre
dans le jeu plutôt que deux
de recevoir le truc et d'être victime de
tout ça vous avez vous voyez que le mec
qui est mal à l'aise on fait bien sûr
c'est hyper facile
le gars il vient idrac déjà moi je sais
quand c'est entre drague des agressions
les gars ils aiment bien nous drague et
nous on aime bien draguer faut aussi
faire attention parce qu'il ya une hyper
un hyper truc de valence en séduction en
fait on parle pas de séduction c'est
enfin aujourd'hui les filles elles font
elles font elles mélangent tout je suis
d'accord mais si elle est gâtée dérive
là dessus aussi
après il ya des filles qui sont vraiment
harcelés comme passer d'un extrême à
l'autre
le point qu'on a c'est qu'il ya les
jeunes filles sont vraiment arçelik qui
passe vraiment des mondes et oui les
gars sont ici et le problème c'est que
on les prend mois au sérieux parce que
il ya des témoignages qui sont un peu
limite donc forcément ça atténue les
vrais syriens disent il est vrai père
sourire avec imane inverse quand même
aux liens ont mis quelque chose dans
notre société aujourd'hui qui est que
l'on n'ose même plus inviter une
collaboratrice à déjeuner en tête à tête
donc je veux dire c'est pas dégueulasse
bilan non mais je sais plus qui disait
j'ose plus appeler une collaboratrice ou
un collaborateur le week end veut dire
le harcèlement le problème est simple de
roche passe et après pour rebondir et
venise et aline je vous rappelle il
avoue même que le plus grand scandale a
eu lieu il ya pas très longtemps dans le
milieu du mannequinat où il ya quand
même plein de gamine qui se sont fait
violer phare d'ailleurs celui qui s'est
suicidé il ya pas très longtemps là non
chez lui quand il s'appelle la personne
non non non et non et et patrouillé dans
un mannequin qui était en taule aux
états unis mais il ya eu quand même des
violences et des mannequins de 14 ans
effroyable qui ont été utilisés dans des
partouzes et dans les trucs donc on n'en
est pas loin quand même
je sais à quel point je t'adore mais il
ya des femmes qui ne savent pas dire non
il faut penser à elle à toutes ces
victimes qui n'ont pas cette même force
de caractère
je sais que je suis parti de mon stage
j'ai préféré [ __ ] le camp mais il ya
des femmes malheureusement qui n'arrive
pas à dire non on va voir ce qu'on
pensait téléspectateurs s'il vous plaît
le harcèlement
oui à 75 par horizon non à 25% donc les
trois quarts des personnes mais c'est
normal qui va ça parce que en fait
benjamin a dit il ya plein de noms et on
veut pas lui dire parce que nous on est
quelque part aussi ont malgré tout mais
on va voir